I've started writing a play when it's
finished I want the two of you
to play the leading roles and what
should you call it master watch maker
welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my
watchmen episode 1 video there's all
kinds of comic book Easter eggs this is
meant to be a sequel series to the comic
book not the movie so we'll break it all
down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing an HBO now giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite watchmen moment
on the video careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet will do
top 10 WTF and easter eggs starting with
number 10 the flashback to the
this is actually a real event happening
in 1921 but there's a lot of plays
within plays stories within stories
they're doing a very tales of the black
freighter within the series poor
characters are watching stories or
listening stories or reading stories
about the story within the story so it
gets really meta if you didn't read the
original comic series or you haven't
seen the movie tales of the black
freighter which is an in-universe comic
book story that told the story of what
was happening in the actual Watchmen
story only was old-timey pirates if
you're not familiar with this in real
world history this actually happened it
was basically 1921 just this giant
of all these people it was
really terrible but they do a really
good job of connecting it to what's
happening in present day as well as some
of the characters in present day through
Lou Gossett Jr's character number 9 you
transitioned to present-day Tulsa
Oklahoma on that same road where Lou
Gossett jr. as a little boy crashed the
cop gets taken down by the cavalry
member sort of setting off the action of
the episode and they want you to believe
that the cavalry has been dormant for a
long time and they've come back and
there's the big villain that everybody
needs to take down but we don't really
find out till the end of the episode
that they're really only a small part of
this grand conspiracy as Lou Gossett
Jr's character teases but obviously the
next big easter egg is the Rorschach
mask they spend a lot of time during
this opening scene kind of letting you
know what the rules are in present day
so the cops actually can't unlock their
guns unless a dispatcher does it back at
the base but there's all kinds of modern
technology that they've derived from doctor
Manhattan so if it wasn't clear you see
all these cars driving around like
even Angela or sister night whatever you
want to call her drives around in an old
school looking muscle car but it's
electric all their cars are electric
based on the science that they were able
to derive from doctor Manhattan by studying
his abilities the soundtrack was amazing
we get our first cues for the Nine Inch
Nails music Atticus Ross and Trent
Reznor are doing the music for the
series the cool thing is is they
actually found out that HBO was making a
watchmen series and reached out to HBO
to try and do the music for before HBO
reached out to them number eight you go
to present-day you see Angela teaching
them how to bake cookies there's a lot
of Easter eggs in this scene tooth they
also convey a lot of history through her
exposition so there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs there's a doctor Manhattan
stream on national television that's
running 24/7 he's on Mars
constructing and destroying things while
she's talking about the exact same thing
it's a big metaphor for what's happening
with doctor Manhattan right now so it's
clear that he's back at least in
relative proximity to earth he's not in
a different galaxy because at the end of
the original comic series and at the end
of the movie he implied that he was
leaving to go to a different part of the
universe but at some point I guess it's
implied that he came back and he's
basically next door just a couple
planets away when she's making the moon
cakes when she cracks the eggs it turns
into The Watchmen smiley face with a
little blood spatter they gave you a
little history lesson on the Vietnam
the reason why it's a state is because
of what doctor Manhattan did during the
Vietnam with a comedian they make a
reference to Robert Redford being
president you see him in the background
here he's been president for the last
30-plus years ever since Nixon and we
find that they put Nixon on Mount
Rushmore right next to Lincoln they also
reference something called red for
Dacians which is basically reparations
from Robert Redford and I think that has
something to do with the white knight
that they referenced so number seven the
white knight they don't completely
explain it but I felt like they give you
enough to know what happened and it's
supposed to be the last major attack
that the cavalry perpetrated on all the
law enforcement agents which is the
basis for why they all wear masks now
they make a reference to not paying
taxes later during the interrogation I
also believe that people who were part
of that don't have to pay taxes anymore
to as part of those red fur Dacians
number six is raining squids so a siren
goes off while they're driving down the
street and it immediately just starts
hailing down all these tiny square
if it's no big deal like it's been going
on for a long time they even have a
special cleanup crew like you have the
garbage men that come around picking up
people's trash cleaning up all the
squids there's even a little symbol on
the back of this truck we don't know why
that's happening but they make a
reference to a transdimensional attack
conspiracy so I think that has something
to do with Ozymandias but they don't
completely reveal that there were a lot
of Ozymandias references to the original
series at the end of the episode that
I'll get to and one of those was to the
squid that he teleported into New York
at the end of the comic series pretty
safe bet that these tiny squid that are
hailing down have something to do with
that one of the squids when it rains
down is the kids looking at it even
muscies up to look kind of like a
Rorschach inkblot they were also a lot
of Rorschach references when they were
interrogating that prisoner too but
number 5 the American hero story TV show
that's another tales of the black
freighter type of device the way they're
using it a show within the show
commenting on what the actual TV show is
about but it's basically meant to be a
TV show about The Adventures of the
original Minutemen because you remember
that in history Watchmen actually
happens though doctor Manhattan was around
all the events of the original movie in
many years before that the adventures of
the Minutemen there's a reference on Lou
Gossett Jr's newspaper that Adrian Veidt
is dead that's awesome man Diaz so the
world believes that he's dead which we
know is not true because he totally
shows up at the end of the episode over
in Wales we hear the Cavalry's manifesto
it's not clear what their mission is
they don't find out what their mission
is by the end of the episode they only
know that they were doing something with
really old-school batteries old-school
watch batteries that is no surprise
watches are very important to Watchmen
the idea of the watch itself but also
the Doomsday Clock there were several
references to that like their big chant
is tik-tok which is a literal reference
to the Doomsday Clock of the original
series but the Doomsday Clock itself is
actually a real-world thing is sort of
the countdown to nuclear annihilation
like during the Cold War how close were
we to actually firing missiles on Russia
and how close were they to firing
missiles on us a lot of that gets into
the idea of the grander conspiracy that
they teased during the episode in that
also sort of dovetails with what's going
on with Ozymandias at the end he says
I'm writing a new play that'll become
more clear in the next couple of
episodes the translation on the Latin
phrase that they all chant isn't quite
perfect but it has something to do with
the
guards who guard themselves when we go
into Don Johnson's office she's sitting
there drinking from an owl mug another
night owl reference
there's a giant police spec owl ship
later in the episode all kinds of night
owl references there's a lots of owls
hooting through the episode you actually
hear real owls in the middle of the
night I think the significance of the
mug though is just to the original night
owl who used to be a police officer
before he took up the name night owl and
became a vigilante number for the
interrogation so they throw the suspect
into what they're calling the pod and
you get to see what Looking Glass does
he doesn't have any special powers he
just really good at interrogating people
and this is meant to be a sophisticated
version of a Rorschach inkblot test they
eventually beat the information about
the ranch out of him but their home base
so number three the Battle of the cattle
ranch a literal cattle ranch but also
their secret hideout they don't really
make it clear how big their group is but
they're obviously called the seventh
Cavalry that's actually a reference to
Custer Little Bighorn like she gets the
pager call with the message that says
Little Bighorn
that was where Custer died at the Battle
of Little Bighorn apparently they don't
care about collateral damage because
they mow through all their own cattle to
get at the police but probably my
favorite moment from this big fight
scene was the reveal of the our ship is
revealed that Don Johnson and his
copilot who's actually named pirate
Jenny which is also a reference to the
song pirate Jenny which was used during
the Watchmen movie and is also an
important idea the watchmen comic book
series they're in a version of an owl oh
shit that looks like it was spectate for
police use like maybe niteowl to sold
his technology to the government or to
the police force because it seems like
they built a brand-new version it's not
the original allo ship it's just another
law enforcement vehicle that probably
other police departments all over the
country have they never quite figure out
what the batteries are for that they
were trying to escape with but that will
probably come back around in the next
couple of episodes number two speaking
of coming back around welcome back
Ozymandias so if it wasn't clear from
all the Easter eggs and foreshadowing
Jeremy Irons is playing the older
version of Ozymandias that apparently
the world thinks is dead they shot all
of his scenes in Wales which I believe
is where this is meant to be so he has
this vast country estate in Wales and
he's just been hiding out this whole
time living this really weird eccentric
life apparently clothes are optional
like he says it's a big deal that he's
putting clothes on
I felt like it was pretty clear the
anniversary that they were referring to
even if you didn't read the original
comic series they're referring to the
original event at the end of the comic
series where he teleported a giant squid
into New York City to make people
believe that there was an alien attack a
transdimensional attack which they also
kind of referenced during the
interrogation earlier you see the play
that he's writing he talks about it
later he calls it the watchmakers son
which is obviously a reference to doctor
Manhattan who is literally the son of a
watchmaker when he says a in
five acts that's gonna be broken up
through five acts of the TV show over
the course of nine episodes the cake is
yellow designed to look like his classic
watchmen comic book costume but also the
pattern of the icing is made to look
like the squid draped over the top right
now he is kind of giving off a villian
vibe which is kind of the way he came
off during the original series but just
like he was in the original comic series
he isn't necessarily an evil person he's
trying to advance the cause of humanity
but he's doing it like he says through
fear so that might have something to do
with them reining squids on everyone all
the time and this growing conflict with
the seventh Cavalry in the Oklahoma
Police the watch that they give him as a
gift is the watch from the original
Watchmen comic book series that's why it
seems like he's triggered a little bit
when he sees it like he's surprised he's
a little bit of a flashback you know
obviously number one WTF was the ending
of the episode where sister night finds
Lou Gossett jr. claiming to have hung up
Don Johnson's character but it's pretty
clear that she doesn't believe that he
did the job but they also don't believe
that the seventh Cavalry was responsible
so somebody else is messing with them
here in Don Johnson's character that
also will probably dovetail with
Ozymandias his brand new plan overall it
was a great setup there's a lot of
bigger stuff in play here like they make
it seem like this is all about the
police versus the cavalry but then they
blow that up at the end of the episode
by making it seem like it's a way way
bigger thing going on so if you spotted
any big Easter eggs during the episode
that I didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments and let
me know what your favorite part was I'll
wait to see how everyone feels about the
series after this first episode and how
this video does before I plan a whole
bunch more Watchmen videos but if you
guys liked it in the video does well I
will do all the episodes the
Mandalorian star wars series is also
in a couple weeks to Rick and Morty is
coming back there's a whole bunch of
stuff coming up including The Witcher
Netflix series I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post my next watchmen
video everybody click here to watch that
Star Wars Episode 9 teaser trailer
and click here for that Game of Thrones
prequel trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight